these are private victims usually
they're individuals they lose tens of
thousands of pounds and we believe in
this scam potentially people have lost
up to and above six ribosomes and before
the victims newer thing police raided
this alleged boiler room just a few
months after it was thought with the gun
dressed to impress these people are said
to have been selling fake investments in
thirty six billion dollars of largely
non-existent Californian gold you are
all under arrest for conspiracy to
defraud this isn't an office in some
abandoned Business Park you're looking
at the heart of London's financial
district you may already be working here
as a banker a broker a lawyer and if you
are the UK police may want you to work
for them starting this year the first
time somebody who may have reached the
position of prominence and importance in
another field makers the army business
will now be able to transfer those
skills to the police but would you be up
to the task you might face opposition
from within the ranks you might have to
take a pay cut but you might also be in
charge of the next raid uncover the next
financial scam all in a day's work